major news from the Maga riots Stuart
Rhodes the founder of the right wing
Oath Keepers group has been sentenced to
18 years in prison for his role in
seditious conspiracy surrounding the
January 6th Maga riots this is a serious
sentence the NBC news report reads the
founder of The far-right Oath Keepers
has been sentenced to 18 years in
federal prison in connection with the
January 6th attack on the capital
following his conviction on seditious
conspiracy the sentence for Stuart
Rhodes is the longest imposed on a
January 6th defendant to date in a
politically charged courtroom before
sentencing Rhodes called himself a
political prisoner and said when he
talked about regime change in a phone
call with supporters earlier this week
he meant he hopes that Trump will win in
2024.
the judge disagreed and says you sir
present an ongoing threat and apparel to
this country and to the Republic and to
the very fabric of this democracy
um
wow so I want to say a couple of things
about this
one of the things I don't do unlike the
right which says lock this person up
lock that person up throw away the key
death penalty all these different things
I have not once said
I want them to crush these rioters and
throw them in prison for life or
whatever what I have said is we have
evidence that crimes were committed so
folks should be charged and then they
should go through the legal process and
if they are convicted they should be
sentenced fairly in according to
sentencing guidelines for the crimes for
which they are convicted that's Law and
Order
and all of these right Wingers who want
to shout that they are for Law and Order
while they demand Hillary be locked up
and they demand that Biden be locked up
and Hunter Biden all this stuff you're
not actually for Law and Order if you
want to deny people uh due process and
so all along I have said there are very
serious allegations surrounding many of
these Trump rioters but I want Justice
to be done and that means that I'm not
going to go around demanding people be
locked up at all or for amounts of time
that don't correspond to the crimes they
have committed here we have a situation
where Stuart Rhodes was found guilty of
seditious conspiracy that's a very
serious crime there are those who will
say the pro the mere prosecution of
these individuals is politically
motivated or all these the judges
remember a lot of these judges are Trump
appointees if you actually can
demonstrate that there was wrongdoing or
mishandling of these cases do it uh they
all get their right to appeal but we are
now seeing that these are serious crimes
which juries of these individuals peers
have decided there is enough evidence to
convict so now Stuart Rhodes is facing
uh eight facing he's been sentenced to
18 years I always forget whether there
are any situations with Federal
sentences where you get time off for for
good behavior maybe he will serve close
to that full 18 maybe he will not uh
this is a reminder
hopefully even though there have not
been consequences to the the top level
insiders like Trump and we'll see if
there are any consequences this is a
reminder that you might want to allow
peaceful transitions of power to take
place rather than doing what these
criminals and we can say now that they
are criminals have done all right so
we'll see if there are any longer
sentences but to date 18 years the
longest coming out of the Maga riots
Monday Memorial Day folks we're off on
Monday for Memorial Day but remember
we'll be doing our one day membership
special get notified by getting on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com if you're
like me and you love The Nostalgia of
enjoying a bowl of cereal sometimes as
an adult check out our sponsor magic
spoon magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal with the crunchy sweet goodness
you love but with zero grams of sugar
more protein and only four to five net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb if you're doing keto if you're
like me and you just don't want to eat a
bunch of sugar magic spoon has delicious
flavors to choose from cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter Honey Nut cinnamon
roll birthday cake my favorite is maple
waffle and right now they have limited
edition spring flavors strawberry
milkshake and peaches and cream
sometimes you just feel like sitting
down with a bowl of cereal when the mood
strikes go for something with plenty of
protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below